hey guys hello thank you for coming to
dislike the gamey snake and everyone
else that has tuned in I appreciate it
it's Tuesday means it's definitely to
destiny destiny to weekly update stream
from us here at game spot I'm Eric
nothing major this week I think that our
bigger news is gonna come Thursday with
a Bungie update we'll probably find out
if you know next week's iron banner or
faction wars I think they're gonna give
a better idea in terms of like the
calendar of what it's gonna look like
for the rest of the month and kind of
going into probably the next expansion I
think the game director is gonna talk as
well so looking forward to that update
but in the time for the time being we're
gonna do our weekly stuff we're gonna do
the nightfall first this week is prism
with an arms dealer sorry it's arms
dealer with prism as well as time zero
time warp killing time geez I can't talk
today I do need one more person on PC so
if you're on PC in the US unfortunately
sorry Richard
we're not playing in the UK today if you
want to hit me up with your battle tag I
can invite you
I'm gonna grab Aaron here hopefully he
joins might be busy and then trying to
invite him through the fireteam but he's
in the tower currently what's up T oh
man
klerken as well as Kevin Valencia yo
what's up thank you guys all for tuning
in we if you didn't know we are live
every day at 11 a.m.
fix something real quick cool so you
guys should tune in as mentioned
Wednesday is normally the lobby but it's
on a little bit of a hiatus for now so
we kind of do some studio stuff figure
out what we want to do so we might be
doing some just kind of like filler
Wednesday streams I think tomorrow I'm
gonna be on a stream with Rob where Rob
will be on stream with a new game that
he's got that he wants to check out
Thursday we're gonna do some World of
Warplanes
robbed again it's gonna be handling the
sticks there and in terms of like
piloting and whatnot and then Friday at
first I thought it was gonna be a a
certain game but it might not happen
because I think we got our dates wrong
so uh hello to the person in whose name
I probably can't read sorry
apologies but yeah uh I'll give it a
couple more material and actually we'll
go do crucible match while we're waiting
here hit me up if you want to run the
night ball I need a third person I mean
maybe maybe tweeting this out welp let's
do that
hopefully everyone's having a good time
a good Tuesday yesterday we did some pub
G Farex the cat yeah I don't know if we
can do dragon ball because I don't think
it's actually out till Saturday think we
got our dates mixed up so it is my fault
see if I get I need a third on PC for
the nightfall in destiny to hit me up
here or on the stream come watch and
let's get this link real quick
[Music]
boom okay what's up Randy Orton you're
gonna RKO some people today DBZ does
release at the end of the month goob
however there is a beta this weekend if
you pre-order I believe you can play a
day earlier otherwise I think it is a
open beta just calling me Ramsey what's
up Ramsey thank you
d2 is so depressing now it depends I
think that like on a week like this
after we cut off come off the dawning
it's a little bit depressing I guess
because there isn't kind of new stuff to
do looks like next week we'll probably
have some some a little bit better luck
in terms of that kind of stuff oh we can
ask Joey that's right
I forgot about Joey
I forgot Joey plays on PC yeah we'll do
that actually that'll be the fastest
route to success here
what's up mod 2's Michael Cole asking
what do people still play this garbage
I think it's garbage for some people I
still enjoy it there are like I said
times when it's a little bit less it's a
little bit lighter especially once you
maxed out your characters but I still
enjoy it I still have friends that I
play on the regular in terms of a
console I still read with them once a
week I still find that experience a lot
of fun but I can understand why a lot of
people don't aren't happy with the game
open to suggestions in terms of streams
if you guys enjoyed the pub G stream
yesterday with me and Nick maybe we do
that more often not sure hard to say but
January is a pretty open month rameses
we are gonna play Metal Gear survive
once the beta hits I think that beta
hits on the e 18th if I got that date
correct
in which case okay cool we got Joey
coming on sweets in which case you know
tune in obviously on the 18th for that I
think that same week next week we'll
have Monster Hunter World beta again the
last beta before the release so come
tune in for that probably have been
Janka possibly been djenka and John Luke
so yeah goof shew riot still hasn't done
the raid rip the clan we can try it's
not that hard anymore to be honest we
can try to get six people I don't know
minecraft stream bro
I've gotten into Minecraft funny story
yesterday like right before my
recreational like basketball league
there was a coach that was talking to
you know I think that the the kids were
maybe maybe like around six to eight
years old probably closer to eight she
was saying you know at the end of their
practice make sure you guys watch this
like practice video before you guys play
minecraft and all the kids were like oh
and I was like no kids do what she says
this game is basically pay to win
obviously you don't know this game at
all extension extinction to zero for
nothing in the paid in the
microtransactions actually affects the
game it's all cosmetic so you clearly
have that wrong I don't know if you've
ever played destiny to but you will not
really net anything from this store the
closest thing that you get from the
store is the is the coin which I'll show
you actually use one but you can get
this from bright dust fire team
medallion but you can get this from
bright dust which you get from various
things that you earn in the game through
bright engrams which you can earn in the
game breaking down like a ship will be
like a hundred bright dust which will
allow you to buy two coins I don't know
why I'm explaining all that but yes here
we go we're gonna go do the nightfall
again this week is prism which means we
need a match an element to whatever it
says on the screen to do more damage
otherwise we want to use kinetic damage
and the way to add more time is to kill
stuff so we're on arms-dealer it's solar
right now I have no solar I'm going to
be using my hand
until the polarization changes
all right so far so good further into
the face out it ghosts definitely you
can earn an exotic ghosts are actually
radical Greek beard I would implore you
to do the raid layer if you enjoy the
doing like rate activities it's because
the rate layer in my opinion is probably
the funnest thing that's been added to
this expansion
but it is actually probably one of the
best bosses mechanically
exotic ghosts do affect the game they
can but nothing nothing is like game
changing like it's not a gun it's not
like armor arc I have way more damage
now I got blown up that's actually bad
mod I hope she isn't oh that makes sense
as to why I got destroyed so so quickly
those guys are all arc
Thank You Aaron so the v5
yeah I can understand a little harder
once we're planning it's kind of social
stop playing
no boys oh I almost died there
oh boy polarization my inability to deal
with it alright just run we should
probably be running to start to begin I
was only doing like 70 damage
clearly all guys are cute
get you jack fret down
but yeah it's kind of rough once you
kind of hit that uh 335 and whatnot on
all your characters there isn't really
much reason for it I understand that I
was kind of hoping that this week would
be factions or
your own ship
why'd they have to give up on their
visions I don't think they Kohli gave up
just Eric today yeah on the destiny days
I'm already kind of getting some of
those guys on from outside trying to be
efficient cabal usually like to be found
he should have been another halo I mean
a lot more games are actually koppány
copying Destiny's formula which is more
open has more chances for good content
it's like MMO life
go back together family and
yeah I mean if people are starting to
not enjoy the Destiny stuff on a weekly
basis I can make it I do it for the
corner of our articles as well because
we always have a weekly article 2018 is
the year for you guys
Piper shank apart
not solar I was like why is it my stuff
radical Greek Pierce's Portland's tree
is gonna be awesome I love Beauregard's
I hope so
I have to I hope they have some settings
that I can change in Borderlands 2
because we're lands - made me really
sick for whatever reason
I did not 10 year plan can't imagine was
his plan
[Music]
I was really close
no it changed the solar dang it
so if you really time it on the boss
later you can really like just destroy
them the supers
you just fall off
and I feel like I feel like that means
like the new pot everyone just loves to
hate on
they switched everything that ever worse
I don't know man like I feel like a lot
of that stuff just like whatever I read
that they rebooted D to six months
what's up canal supa clash from
brassiere
come on come on arc is my muss my jam
it's not solar anymore I mean it's not
arguing yes
that poverty kinetic damage life
what's up Petey
100 gentle touch
I got fired
hello from Croatia what's up koron
feel like I'm not
I love to the best of my ability
Konrad kinetic at this point don't get
smashed guys
what's after void Ark Oh hurry up hurry
up I want it to be arc about time we get
up there
did the game get good yet depends on how
you look at it come on show up
no short the canoe is short now we've
got you
all right
like solar got solar I don't have any
solar oh they're all so
the game did not get good yet okay at
least not this week
work welcome no no but not gonna do
anything right now
get away - Joey
guns Oh oh my god stop giving my snipers
and stupid pulse can't rifles
Joey carried that I doubt it yeah yeah
Joey carried it and I don't think so
yeah it's an easy weakness this week
Paula can I would say prisons why the
second easiest modifier outside of
outside of torrents torn is by far the
easiest
came the one hopefully Thursday we find
out more about all four things you just
mentioned until then we'll be what we
said we'll be waiting in the wings we
got to be something crucible I guess
right now
Oh quick that Nova pumps that noble bomb
was like five seconds early maybe 10
seconds early
I feel like if he had waited for void
polarization he would have killed it way
faster than I did with the Rockets but
you know whatever all good yeah that was
a nightfall pretty eventful you know I
don't like how juggler is a full-time
modifier in the game now I guess I don't
know I grenades are pretty strong
especially pulse grenades they kind of
nerfed it a little bit but it's still
really good
what's up diabolic date yeah die bollock
die bollock tame a man he says I'm a new
and YouTube's need your opinion
what's up monster Diaw Tech I can try to
give you my opinion as long as it's um
you know reasonable and doesn't require
me to you know say anything bad or
anything like that looking forward to
playing dragon ball fighters though this
weekend try to get some practice in I
guess we'll fire stream in one day
finally got rid of my ex bone for good
any chance this game comes to switch
probably not have a havoc strawberry
probably not hello svetislav Georgiev oh
hey you're you're back nice to see you
man thanks Cookie Monster
I'm usually there oh you're on I'll get
you on get you Sanchez right to fighter
team I play destiny to level eight for
free and you promotion I'm brown and got
my fix on that bye I think the score
game so I gave it is as fair as it gets
for d2 or 4d to the curse of Osiris
Christopher Cyrus isn't very great to be
honest sadly it's one of the weaker
expansions today out sided the the the
the Raider is pretty fun came the once
it's funny I was poorly optimized as the
division is on console and how well this
game is in preparing soon I still rather
put up with the jank in the division
because the gear sets grind a variety of
content that's fair the vision has
actually it's it's tough I played a lot
of division when it first came out and I
was on it for a while and then all the
exploits and everything kind of soured
it for me and a lot of the community but
I think there's been a resurgence for
them more recently they've had some
pretty big updates come through and some
seem pretty interesting I think that
horde mode that their gear sets as
mentioned are more interesting as cane
the one has mentioned it they really
borrowed from like a diablo style sense
I guess they they I believe I don't even
know I'm not sure if they've actually
ever said specifically that they use
Diablo as a as a as a helping helpful
tool but definitely the gear sets and
things like that very much remind me of
like Diablo Wow and that is cool like I
kind of wish there was more of that
stuff here I wish there was more
interesting exotics and destiny too
there aren't really any there's a lot of
rehash d1 stuff I think there's all
a handful of exotics in destiny - that
are new that have been actually like oh
that's really cool like Orpheus Riggs
for example is by far one of the best
hunter exotics because it does something
interesting and like worthwhile for
everyone and yourself as a hunter but a
lot of the other exotics are kind of
even though they've gotten some new
abilities they've they're kind of just
not that great I I don't use like a lot
of them I almost exclusively only use
skull fort because of how good it is to
get grenades back alpha Lupe's okay like
I think on torrent you can spam the wall
to get light back that's kind of cool
this extra kind of jump thing for lion
rampant yeah that's fine they look cool
but like nothing feels that great sweet
business as a weapon type is cool but
it's it doesn't really do much for me
visually and swing decent PvP weapon
colony is a is a good is a fun exotic
like that's cool like there should be
more like exact should be special they
should do something special and they a
lot of them currently don't do that
so yeah Kane the once I see and as well
as radical Greek beer says the one point
up 1.8 Update is great gear is amazing
the comment is superb content is very
well done yeah so I played on xbox
because that's the the code I had from
the beginning do you guys were for
radical Greek beard and came the one
let's say I wanted to get back into the
vision let's say I wanted to start on PC
though is is it really hard to kind of
get up to those higher levels and all
the materials because there was a lot of
grinding and a lot of farming in terms
of like division tech trying to you know
get perfect rolls I'm all about the
perfect rolls by the way like I think
that's a cool system it kept me playing
the division for a while there's a
little frustrating in terms of like
trying to get the god role but I would
rather have trying to hunt for the god
role like destiny one hand than to not
have that in the game so yeah do you
guys know if no sins why I just I like
curtain call
I have sins sins is probably better for
PvP that's a good shout fan 23 fan but
yeah
I think yeah diabla has said that yeah I
think the division got a lot better it's
probably better than destiny right now I
probably can't agree with that even
though I haven't played too much
Division I kind of want to air anew if I
want to start streaming the division
again now that it's gotten an update I'm
interested for sure but uh just not sure
what kind of time communion it would
take to to do that so yeah I mean if
it's a if it's a plausible to kind of
like start back up maybe I can do that
okay I killed that guy but I struggled
with the other guy I guess I should just
use a hand cannon and not even bother
with Auto it is very different like it
feels like a very different PvP meta in
on PC compared to console because
there's so much more
what I could name gets home okay that
one finish them off boys actually I
really like or is it old fashioned in a
console PvP or PC
PvP because it's just I don't know hang
cannons in general just feel a lot
better on aiming past him and I totally
just whipping yeah okay that's that's
fair I don't I don't have a colony on PC
yet - that's kind of sucky yeah a lot of
people have said that yes the division
has improved yes it definitely has
improved Wow I'm playing like just
absolutely donk right now
all right warming up warming up
hopefully Leo stop sucking that's the
key to stop sucking we are winning
though so I guess
on first I guess it's not that bad
they made it easier to get back into
you'll notice it started a fresh
character and it's taken me about a
month ago i grinding about four to five
hours a week oh really that's it that's
not bad
do you have like a full set of kit now
run from the spider mines damn well
let's kill that guy see I didn't have to
run I guess we could've traded that one
please stop oh I thought that I thought
I already got hit by the spider is this
live yes this is live
what's up slightly Dudley
close game
although it's just missing blogs okay I
see
you jumped away
I was hoping I would have back up but my
back up there tonight
although chalkboard What's Up boo yellow
Sanchez popping his hammers how does he
have super let's begin like actual more
kills
all I missed everything so that money
four to five to four to five hours is
not bad if it's only four to five hours
a week yeah maybe maybe we'll have to
just get back on that train look at that
three shot three shot with the
old-fashioned
whoa
okay yeah just walk into it
I got on with the grenade I just ran out
of super or would have got that hunter -
where's that where's that we got a team
shot this guy oh I keep getting side
busted on ya they're just walking into
the ground pounds yes that's correct
I don't know why but they are
I heard you I heard your footsteps
at the angle - we should win unless we
just finally choke this well Anthony the
Destiny killers [ __ ] grimy uh it's
hard to say man there's a lot of uh a
lot of worried that it's an EA game
there's a lot of fear that it's you know
it's a EA game there's gonna be a lot of
loot boxes are although I want to say
there was like a report out like
yesterday but I think it was an analyst
so don't take it with a grain of salt
I think that's an analyst that said that
it won't have loot boxes or if it does
it's only gonna be cosmetic and it won't
affect the game here's the hoping that
that's the case if so then I'm
definitely interested in anthem it looks
cool but we've only seen one gameplay
demo that was probably a scripted
gameplay demo so we don't even know
exactly how everything's gonna work it
looks cool but who knows Eric Conn oi
hey you got a squad for pub GPC or Xbox
all bueno for me I don't have a squad
actually yesterday was the first time
I've ever ran a solo pub G match and I
got really lucky and got like 7th I
think and I've only played like duo's
like three or four times with Jake on
Xbox so I probably played like five
times on Xbox considering playing on PC
because Nick wants me to play on PC but
I don't know maybe we'll see Eric thanks
for stopping by again though if anthem
comes out this year I'm not playing that
grindy games as blimey eh uh yeah I
don't know we no no it's it's so much
speculation right now we don't know any
like I can't speak on it properly
Alexander Lee let most yes I'm currently
playing on PC also playing ps4 though
SuperMario it happens but it keeps our
chat intimate I'm happy you're here and
I'm happy you're chatting with us
don't know Christopher gist or Geist
if Tekken 7 can't be bought as an arcade
cabinet in the u.s. we have Tekken 7
cabs though in the office we have two of
them
yeah cool that was a we did pretty solid
there I don't have any crucible tokens
all right pops um at least we got fire T
medallion I want that last match I would
have liked to get a hand canyon so I
could 335 the old fashioned but
unfortunately got a pulse rifle would
also like a colony on PC that'd be
pretty nice to have just to have fun in
PvP but this is a gauge of pure combat
potential make me proud
yeah if you guys are itching to see
something on stream or why not telling
me hit me up or if there's any what was
that and how did he okay he must be
lagging right did everyone see me mate
Mele whiffed they're like I guess it
didn't whatever it's fine we traded
could've been worse
oh I can't wait to see what you do with
that damn so using sweet business
Bunji is the true destined killer I
don't know about that man they listen to
the community man I mean sometimes it
doesn't happen as fast as people
probably want it to happen but they take
feedback to heart but someone else made
like this really interesting point that
was like what if all of us that are like
defending destiny myself included treat
destiny like it's like a sports
franchise right I'm really sorry that I
don't know that person who wrote this
article or this brought up this that way
it's kind of stuck with me that like you
know like real talk I've been a worse
fan since I was a kid this is free like
you know Kady
free us winning a championship all that
so please do not call me a bandwagon say
that now that I said that and you know
I've always rooted for them right good
and bad whatever what if like it's the
same like for Dad oh it's the same for
destiny for me like I'm trying to defend
and continue to support this game
because I do still enjoy it but you know
obviously it has kind of I would say
downhill is really harsh it's kind of
gone down a little bit you know even for
me who loves the game but I want to keep
believing because I want it to succeed
you know and maybe that's why
I'm so I guess yeah I'm just like
invested you know at this point five
minutes remaining
was it Lehman gaming said that thank you
Shasha pardon thank you for that
yeah it was just a and I thought about
it I was like that resonates like quite
a bit like that totally makes sense
okay Jesse - is garbage not true
it still has probably some of the best
feeling shooting mechanics the best like
some of the best sound design like guns
destiny one had more content ah which
destiny one are we talking about cuz if
we're talking just bass destiny one that
no you were wrong sir it had a lot less
it was only over time that it became a
lot better
I'm not dispelling the fact that yeah
there are definitely some stuff that was
in definitely one that is no longer
indefinitely - I don't dispute that at
all
but to say that destiny - has less
content than destiny one is like depends
on which destined one we're talking
about here but if we're talking a
vanilla destiny one there's no way I'm
crazy and there's so much quality of
life stuff that like you don't even
think about right now
three minutes you're winning
stay strong I'm sorry didn't save you
for one victory imminent don't know why
he uses a rift in them
that's why we destiny to have razors
behind a paywall has rights only the r8
layer is behind the paywall but the
actual rate is in their team no I have a
super got better Devils
please be 335 so we can upgrade our 330
so that we can upgrade our old-fashioned
all I need is 66 yeah I would like to
see 66 come back Alexander I understand
the 4v4 part of it but I'd rather the
four before be like specific modes keep
that - maybe God what is the bomb mode
called
I haven't played in so long it's a
competitive bomb mode where you armed in
defusing I think that could be four
before that's fine like it's fine there
but I want 6v6 control back 66 like
Clash maybe even 66 supremacy like I
miss those days definitely especially
since you know I have about five five or
so friends at least that's so play like
on console and stuff like that that I
raid with and we'd like to I be together
we'd like to iron banner together and we
can like we like to crucible together
like we used to but we can like so then
we have to separate into three are two
separate groups of three and it's like
we wish we could just play with each
other games ball getting that cash from
Activision please stream our game no one
else is I don't think that's true at all
north badger I continue to play it week
to week because I enjoy it and also we
still do weekly updates on the on the
GameSpot site so it's a good place to
put that into we stream other games as
well north badger then doing some pub G
lately we do basically a lot of the I
like to think we do a lot of the newer
games are coming out a lot of the betas
you know early access division overtook
destiny on Twitch yeah division has done
a great job as mentioned they've done a
good job of kind of it's like coming
back kind of like rainbow succeed
just awesome stuff to them I played a
lot of division when it first came out
kind of want to get back into it just
because I do like the the gear sets and
the gear customizability that is in that
game
again I'm a huge Diablo fan so having a
shooter that has like kind of some
Diablo some Diablo styled themes there
in terms of like armor sets and gear and
loot is cool to me I don't know about
saying division was always a 10 out of
10 game DZ was kind of like a cool
concept but I don't think it was like
fully realized the way like it needed to
be and all those exploits definitely
didn't help
I read chat and look for people's
titin baby are that's why I shouldn't
keep shooting yeah can I tell me - is he
really struggling for point forward
months after post release the
communities on fire
the population is as those yeah this is
those are those are true statements that
I cannot hopefully they get their act
together and get fixed kill two of us
I like your framed a picture of Hyrule
Thanks the married video game
[Music]
yeah maybe we'll fire up individuals but
I probably have to level for us to kind
of get up to snuff or need some like
hard carries has someone put me in their
backpack they got it no I'm taking be
right don't advantage is your that's a
power play you took them now hold them
from downtown don't see way past it
I love this I love this about control
everyone just runs in a circle capturing
other points I haven't read that analyst
statement Dylan that would be really
silly because it's like even if you put
all that content into ever verse if you
don't have a good expansion and nobody's
going to play it or buying I want to
defend but then the other team just runs
in a circle
captured keep the pressure on if I'm not
gonna go there if I gotta please don't
your advantage grows stay strong don't
see capture like who knows where the
healthy restaurant
third a of course
No
that's all my entire team blow the
supers what's a Nintendo fan like me
doing here we played Nintendo switch
games to man play everything here
against wide and I appreciate you guys
all tuning in
I'm still gonna die old strong and this
battle is yours
you captured Zone C you have a box don't
be
you play warframe I have not really
played too much warframe Alex Poirot
that's another game that I don't know
wanted to jump into just never did
I heard that one's a little bit more
daunting in terms of just all the
systems in play like this is a kind of
complex piano Aaron but which is bland
bomb in this game has been playing a
little bit more of it just to kind of
see what's up but if there was a game
that I was probably gonna hop into
I always tell myself at Rainbow six
siege can do it destiny if you can do it
yeah it's always possible it's just
about like how much the people do you
lose before you actually fix it in
getting right
Wow good
Oh rat Kings really I have racking what
I know I'm racking I've never done Rat
King
alright whatever I'll take it must have
been someone else must've been somebody
else that need a racking there's
probably yellow Sanchez which makes
sense
where is the lobby met barn
Brenton Bryn it is a little on a little
bit of a hiatus currently so sorry about
that but yeah
when do you get that free lunch a scoop
uh maybe today maybe today my shots on
the guy in the air there lol thanks Kane
the one hi what is more satisfying for
you looting and division or destiny um I
haven't played new division pewter so
it's hard for me to say I I think that
the I think that the loot in the
division is more interesting especially
now where it's at with the sets and
things like that but I think a lot of
the God rules in the division are still
kind of the same like you want like
brutal and like deadly I just like that
stat system war but again I'm a little
biased because I played a lot of Diablo
so having those systems in play in a
shooter is really cool to me yeah and
I'll probably play well probably finish
out our milestone for crucible up right
call it a day but I really again do
appreciate you guys all tuning in we
stream every day at 11 a.m.
well parts start filling the Wednesday
Lobby timeslot as much as we can until
we figure out when we were gonna kind of
bring that back so stay tuned there hit
that sub button if you haven't on
YouTube and join us on hip follow on
Twitch kind of curious if any one that
was might have watched yesterday or
anything like that would be interested
in watching a noob pub G or get better
at pub Gigi I was thinking about that
last night and pub G was a lot of fun to
me I'm still learning I I did more
watching a pub G than I have done
playing but there's a really good time
in Australia playing pub G so maybe that
X Games spot you should see what you can
do with the classified gear now and
ninja bag what's a ninja bag I know
there's more ways to get loot which is
good which is always great and that
horde mode looks pretty interesting did
they answer the free lunch question I
said maybe today she'd like periscope
that
only out of hair still falling
zero is given lost battle is still
closed the other thing out today later
is is the overwatch team skins it out
today
oh wow I got no truth overwatch team
league starts I think tomorrow we're
playing we gotta get better here
do you follow Sanchez guys pretty good
Devils does allow more room for error
because of the area effects but I think
that uh old-fashioned is if your
accurate is probably better done
what's up silence kill
Wow
that guy probably has stomp ease on
stomp these are really annoying you can
jump like a lot higher
bungees next update patch could make a
break for many do you see destiny having
to die rebirth much like the visionary
who succeed I don't think they have to
necessarily get I think they're still
like for the most part okay they just
need to kind of buckle up and kind of
get some of those things to fix and I
think they'll be okay they're not that
far off where they have a rebirth moment
it'll be in September when they probably
release like a complete edition that'll
be like a taking sighs taking king-sized
update probably because there's still
one more small expansion the fallen one
that's a Seva based before we hear about
anything else that's bigger
do you miss the days of one his shoulder
charge them but skull fort would be
broken then I guess at that point what a
great spot I was like playing trials
again on the that one map with the sands
and the Sun outside where you can't see
[ __ ] everyone will go outside and you
just get blinded by the Sun
see
nearly there fight on and claim victory
Hollyweird ends I know that wait to see
what you do with that for the Golden Gun
three minutes remaining
victory we did that we did that alright
guys and gals and everybody really
appreciate everyone stopping by today as
mentioned we will be streaming for the
remainder of the week got some kind of
cool flight polity stuff if you're into
that coming in the next couple days Rob
will be on there so tune in for that of
course 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time
Friday might be a little bit up in the
air now that our Dragonball plans have
fell out a little bit fell through they
will probably be Monday is when we'll
play dragon ball so tune into that for
dragon ball otherwise I think it's open
beta this weekend if I'm remember
correctly so if you want to check that
out you should definitely play it it's
one of the two big games coming out this
month
other than Monster Hunter world next
week we'll have more more streams of
course
monster hunter World I'm like blanking
on all the stuff coming up metal gear
survive a lot of stuff coming out soon
overwatch League is gonna start tomorrow
the skins are out today at some point so
if you're if you want any of the team
skins from overwash league that's out
today at some point we'll be covering
the overwatch league we have some some
folks out there so if you're interested
in the league or getting into watching
that stuff tuning a game spot of course
and until Friday
or well sorry not Friday but until
tomorrow we'll have more stuff more
streams more chats with you guys
appreciate it so you guys have a good
Tuesday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]